il fait moins 20 degrés dans les champs
remplis de carcasses de camions de
moteurs déçu et de différentiel de la
firme lussier une bonne partie de ces
pièces détachées après avoir été
reconditionnés dans l' usine connaîtront
une nouvelle vie sous des cieux plus
cléments à cuba sous la marque terra cam
camions complets autobus scolaire moteur
remis à neuf sont de vieux capot de
camions soviétique
terra cabrol depuis plus de 25 ans sur
les routes de cuba recyclage idéal pour
un pays aux moyens limités le tout
garanti 21 tirs à came de nouveaux
bureaux à la havane 20 employés bientôt
30 les affaires vont rondement 30 juin
on a à compléter notre cinquième mois il
ya quelques semaines puis on a eu une
augmentation de 100 % du chiffre
d'affaires sur cinq mois
c'est nancy lussier qui dirige la
filiale cubaine des camions lussier et
elle partage son temps entre cuba et
sainte-julie où la filiale cubaine
représente maintenant plus de 10% d'un
chiffre d'affaires de 200 millions de
dollars
les vieux moteurs ils ont parfois 30 ans
ont nettoyé tous les éléments usées sont
remplacés par des neufs etc
depuis plus de 25 ans trois générations
de lucie retable des camions des
différentiels des moteurs de a à z
en voici un tout près pour l'expédition
donc ici on a un moteur qui reconstruit
en l'emportant dans nos centres si c'est
vraiment une de nos forces à cuba c'est
vraiment notre marque de commerce et
cuba direction halifax et par bateau le
port de mariel c'est la nouvelle zone
industrielle de cuba pour l'importation
en franchise
l'élu s'ils ont des projets ambitieux et
là on est dans un processus avancé dans
lequel on va transférer peut-être une
partie de notre production directement à
cuba qui on va s'assurer d'avoir les
centres
en place pour aider au maintien de tous
les camions canadiens qui vont être
envoyés vers cuba
malgré les difficultés économiques les
investissements étrangers à cuba se
multiplient les espagnols les français
construisent ou rénovent des hôtels de
grand luxe à laval par exemple les
canadiens sont plus discrets mais ils ne
sont pas inactifs nancy lussier
président la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie canada cuba qui n'a pas
d'équivalent avec d'autres pays dans
l'île une vingtaine de compagnies
canadiennes s'y retrouve
parmi eux deux gros canons sherritt la
compagnie de nickel et cobalt le plus
gros investisseur étranger à cuba et
blue diamond filiale de sandrine qui est
la deuxième chaîne hôtelière de cuba le
québec y est présent c'est la seule
province à avoir un bureau à cuba par
des entreprises c'est un marché qui est
pas simple c'est un marché qu'il faut
bien content donc nécessairement ça
prend de la patience de la persévérance
myriam paquette côté à son bureau à
l'ambassade du canada depuis novembre
2010 est elle discerne déjà quelques
secteurs clés servent au transport
d'énergie
et on a beaucoup d'expertisé au québec
en cette matière n'a qui est en demande
ici à cuba les secteurs de
l'agroalimentaire est un secteur qu'on
veut vraiment réussir à pousser avec
toute la demande pour les produits
notamment dans l'est d'industrie
touristes et ceci dit il manque un outil
essentiel aux compagnies canadiennes
pour faire face à la concurrence des
européens c'est le financement au canada
qui permettrait aux entreprises de
donner le financement qui est demandé
par les entreprises qui versent un
système d'assurance et de crédit à moyen
et long terme que la chambre de commerce
ne cesse de demander à le décès
exportation et développement canada
depuis plusieurs années ce qui
permettrait à lui sied par exemple de
vendre plus facilement des flottes
entières de camions plutôt que des
pièces détachées pour des entreprises
canadiennes qui veulent investir dans
l'infrastructure cubaine ça ferait toute
la différence
[Musique]